entre 4 et 8 mois d'emprisonnement avec
sursis ou bracelet électronique ce sont
les peines qui ont été prononcées à
l'encontre des trois hommes qui avaient
terrorisé des passants et tenter de
jeter l'un d'eux du Pont Wilson dans la
nuit de lundi à mardi très alcoolisée au
moment des faits ils étaient jugés pour
violence aggravée en réunion reportage
de la Turquie
le tribunal de tourtera tranché les
trois individus sont jugés coupables de
violences qui se sont déroulées en
centre ville de Tours quelques jours
plus tôt 4 et 6 mois d'emprisonnement
avec sursis pour deux d'entre eux huit
mois d'emprisonnement délictuels total
avec un aménagement de peine sous forme
de bracelets électroniques pour le
dernier il est aux alentours de 3 heures
du matin sur le pont Wilson quand la
menace éclate je vais te balancer du
pont les premiers coups sont donnés
Place de la Monnaie par deux des accusés
sur la première victime peu de temps
après l'effet se répètent à trois cette
fois-ci des insultes d'écoute point coup
de pied et même une bouteille en verre
brisée sur le visage d'un jeune homme
passant par là les trois individus de 18
19 et 20 ans sont finalement arrêtés par
les forces de l'ordre tous sont testés
positifs à l'alcool deux d'entre eux
avoisine les deux grammes par litre de
sang après ils ont véritablement pris la
mesure des choses parce qu'on n'est pas
face à trois mauvais gamins ce sont des
gens qui sont de manière générale en
série et en réalité même eux n'arrivent
pas à comprendre ce qu'elle puis
accessoires là ce qu'on sait maintenant
c'est qu'il y a probablement une petite
problématique comportementale en cas de
en cas de consommation d'alcool et je
pense que maintenant ils vont travailler
là-dessus du côté des victimes les
traces de cette nuit sont toujours bien
visibles mais fracturées plaies
ecchymose ajoutez au préjudice
émotionnel maintenant j’angoisse dès que
j'entends un bruit derrière moi les deux
victimes constituées partie civiles
toucheront respectivement 2100 euros et
2300 euros de dommages et intérêts